Nicholas II became ruler of Russia in 1894 and immediately told his advisors he had no idea how to run a country.
He said he wasn't prepared and didn't want the job.
His advisors told him to keep that to himself.
Twenty four years later, he and his entire family were executed in a basement.
Three hundred years of Romanov rule ended in about 10 minutes.
That's in a history book almost nobody reads past the opening chapters.
So a team of ex-Ivy League engineers built something that looks exactly like your social feed.
Same scroll, same dopamine.
But every post is a real story from history.
Human, surprising, impossible to forget, condensed into something you can actually keep.
People say they started seeing historical figures as actual people, not statues.
And they always had something worth saying.
Tri-paladin.